hello folks welcome to
rational science you have an exciting
day today
we're going to be talking
about opacity and transparency which uh
we talked about in past couple sessions
and uh today we're gonna
double up on then give you a third clue
that mother nature gives us and how she
does
transparency and opacity but let's begin
first with extinction as
many of you know in this site
we hold that we are the last generation
of humans on earth
that's not because we're pessimistic
no it's because we're realistic okay uh
and no we're not going to die because of
this covid this disease that's out there
or that some people say is out there not
everybody believes that right
now we're going to die because of
economics
our economy is going to fall apart
specifically uh the u.s economy
once the u.s economy falls
apart uh collapses
that's the end of the world for all of
us
and so we have to do everything in our
power
to keep uh
the economy the u.s economy rolling okay
uh i received a message there sounds
like uh
there's some kind of problem with the
video let me know if uh if there's some
problem because i received a message
from youtube saying that there's not
enough video
okay so let me know
if you can see me and hear me
okay
give you a second
can everybody hear me see me
i don't know why youtube
sent me that
okay
thank you
i don't know why youtube sent me that
message there but just so you know okay
so let's get started with
uh
okay thank you
um okay so let's get started with this
covid with there were a lot of questions
a lot of um comments related to that i'm
gonna mention a few of them here okay
here's the first one
first uh says
according to the centers for disease
control i'm sorry this is not a comment
someone made this is uh out of the news
uh it says um centers of disease control
and prevention just 53 percent of
americans are fully vaccinated
majority of people are not okay
or they are but just barely okay just a
little over 50 percent the vast majority
of the people who have become seriously
ill in recent months have not been
vaccinated
okay uh the coronavirus vaccines are
highly effective at preventing serious
illness and death is this uh propaganda
or is this for real
right
uh more than uh 650
654 000 americans have died from
complications related to cobit 19
according to john hopkins university and
more than 40 million have been infected
okay
so those are the statistics uh do you
believe them do you not believe them
you know uh
i don't know i i know that um
there's a tendency human nature
to jack up the numbers especially if
there's a monetary incentive okay
uh you send money if the person dies
because of covet you don't send money if
the person dies of cancer soda you know
that kind of thing
so i don't know i don't know these
numbers are real or not okay in his
speech thursday biden also called out
governors or playing pandemic politics
by resisting mass mandates and
downplaying the power of vaccines okay
so uh
the u.s government is concerned about
the
the
current government biden's government uh
they're worried about elections uh as
always
uh politicians are wondering uh what
effect uh the
uh prolonging of this um coping thing is
going to have on their
uh
election um
abilities uh their your
ability for success for being re-elected
okay the incumbents
okay um here's uh one fella he says how
do you justify the vaccines are the
correct approach using the majority
argument you said 90 doctors are in
favor of vaccines how something works is
objective in its nature that's true and
absolutely and it absolutely does not
matter how many people say that the sun
evol reballs i guess you meant around
the earth for that matter because that
is not how it works and again he's right
on that
uh again i got another message from
uh youtube
uh let me know if something goes wrong
and maybe the most important part is
that you already have natural immunity
to that well you had it until that the
shot
i agree that
i may have had already natural immunity
the issue is that i didn't get the shot
because of i'm trying to protect myself
from any disease i got the shot
because i'm going to be traveling okay
and i don't want the hassle that
goes along with people who do not get
vaccinated okay
uh i traveled to iceland and they put me
in jail i was there for five days until
they let me out
i was in a hotel they fed me great but
uh you know i missed five days of my
vacation and uh i didn't like that too
much so
you know i'm trying to avoid that hassle
and again it's because of all this uh
all these measures that they put out
there okay
okay another fellow says
says uh
okay
uh why would anyone say that they did
not uh take the jab when they
when they did illogical i mentioned that
uh common someone made that maybe a lot
of people who have taken the vaccine uh
uh tell their buddies you know maybe
that they didn't and again uh that's uh
that works both ways it could work in
that direction as well because a lot of
people might say you know just in case
i'm going to get the vaccine i don't
believe i don't believe but just in case
i'm going to get it anyways and then
what he's going to tell his buddies and
she said no no
i don't get the vaccine you know
but uh again uh we don't know if that's
true or not we don't know what people
have out there okay so especially with
all the social pressure it would be more
likely that someone would admit they
took the job when they really when
really they did not i would like to see
your vaccine card for i do not believe
you have taken the jab
show us the proof okay
okay i'll show you the proof here's my
proof okay the little red book okay uh
it's really the
let me get the page where it says uh
here it is
uh this is the little yellow book okay
it shows that i took the i got the
vaccine uh was it on uh
a few days ago
i don't see the day down here i hope it
shows up somewhere
uh anyways i gotta take this little
booklet when i travel
because uh i don't want to be hassled so
yeah i did take get the bike seen i have
no reason to lie i have no reason to
tell anyone otherwise you know in fact i
would have lied in in the opposite
direction i would have said look i
didn't get the vaccine guys don't don't
think i i was stupid enough to get it
now the reason i got is i'm going to be
traveling that's the only reason
[Music]
okay
anyways uh yeah i do have proof that i
got the vaccine anyone who
i'm sure the authorities where i go
will ask me to uh provide proof okay
and uh here's another uh comment really
it's from a
news
article
said eu budget battle looms as economy
lives out of crisis in the 19 states
europe right
uh that used the euro single currency
the average
debt is expected to reach what a hundred
and two percent of gdp at the end of the
year
so uh all these governments here they
have overdrawn
and
you know
but they what they owe now is above
the what the what they produce
and and that's
you know that has to click in your head
that something is not right
and the question is if now they're going
to go with the delta and later on with
the mu or mu or whatever it's called um
will we recover from not from the
vaccine forget about the vaccine the
issue will we recover economically from
all these measures that these people are
taking okay
and uh
the u.s doesn't stand behind stay behind
you know here it is says two years of
massive unemployment this is a comment
someone made will double all previous
raises in debt again i think he's right
and the perfection of this communism
is on its downhill role into perfecting
our form of socialist fascism whoa
big words are mighty words okay the only
economic gain will continue to be the
political class and their business
entities of war and emergencies
business entities the pursuit of
happiness has been strangled by this
present two-year emergency and which has
no end in sight okay
this is the five eyes uh
of the anglophone nations uh five eyes
refers to several countries
english-speaking countries that
uh work together australia new zealand
canada
uk and uh the united states
and uh
well he just rants about this and i
guess uh he's got this vision that uh
it's a totalitarian system looks
something like this you know
comes out of an article that says biden
may put future stimulus checks on
autopilot no vote required
talk about communism you know
and it makes you kind of wonder
what
what is happening out there
is the united states becoming a
totalitarian
slash communist system like this fellow
is suggesting
and i'm sure that if you ask a lot of
people out there they might say it is
especially the
people on the altar right they might say
uh we veered too much to the left
and one of the things that uh
compels that you know is uh china
see china is doing more or less well at
this point in time economically and the
united states is not doing as well
and this is a problem for the world
because uh one
china is catching up economically and
militarily right and united states is
not advancing as fast so here we have
china catching up
and one of the problems that causes is
that
you know the united states takes
measures economic measures against china
because china subsidizes
many of his industries and especially
the united states accuses it whether
it's true or not accuses the government
of china of you know subsidizing many of
its industries and what does that do to
the united states well it forces the
united states to subsidize some of their
industries especially
agriculture
to compete on the worldwide on the world
level and that's communism subsidies is
not free market
and so the question is
the united states prides itself in being
a free market economy but here you have
other countries that decide to subsidize
some of their products and it compels
the united states to subsidize some of
their products forcing the united states
to become a little more communistic and
socialistic right and less capitalistic
free market and so keep that in mind um
you know are we saying that subsidizing
you know communism socialism is more
powerful than capitalism than free
market laser fare
uh you know
are
communist countries or like china or
other countries that subsidize their
industries
compelling the united states to become a
little more communistic
okay so keep that in mind i mean can we
have a totally free market system
or will
governments cheat
okay so that's one thing to keep in mind
fellow says england was the last empire
i'm sure there were plenty of folks in
those days that said england would be
the last empire in the us will never be
an empire
the u.s is the center of the current
empire okay and as we see it is
collapsing from the outside in so the
u.s will be the last to fall we are
witnessing the collapse of europe
australia new zealand japan okay sure
there's going to be a war with china
in the next six years and after the war
the us after the war
the u.s will break up sometime in the
2030s uh
then the empire baton will go to china
empire being the one with the most money
so i guess uh the united states will
become a little um
province a little state of china of the
big empire of china
is this true is this what's going to
happen uh what the united states is
going to
collapse after 2030 and become just
another little tiny fourth world country
uh part of the empire of china is that
what's gonna happen
you know i have doubts i think that um
if there is a war
that's the end of all of us this war is
not going to be anything like wars in
the past and the other thing i have to
say here is that uh yeah
the united states is the last empire and
it's unlike what happened in the 19th
century with england okay there was no
global economy there was no uh we didn't
have the power we have today militarily
right so a lot of those things make a
difference uh do you really think the
united states is going to allow
china to catch up with it militarily
or will it uh preempt you know china
will it uh have uh
what is it called
false flag
create a false flag to uh engage
while it's still ahead
you know what do you think's gonna
happen do you really think uh this falls
right uh there's gonna be a war
and
uh yeah they're gonna fight a little bit
they're gonna give each other a black
guy and then uh the united states just
gonna
fall behind and then china's going to
pass
and become the new empire
i don't think so not at all okay anyways
here's uh mr biden and he had a good
talk with uh mr uh siege from china
premier of china okay and says u.s
president joe biden talked with his
chinese counterpart uh urging they
ensure that competition between the two
parts does not become
conflict okay they're worried about um
the economic uh competition you know the
battle for the dollar i guess or
uh for the renminbi or whatever uh is
gonna
spill over into military action okay
and so uh he gave him a call to say hey
you know
uh kind of look eye to eye through the
phone
saying you know uh we don't really want
this to
convert into some kind of war do we
and so they had a little talk there who
knows what they talked about all you can
do is speculate but yeah there are some
tensions especially the united states
thinks that china is uh unfairly
competing
and again does this compel the united
states to also
uh implement measures which are not free
market
that's what you gotta think
about okay
okay um
now the file says uh just because i say
we are witnessing the extinction of our
current forms of government right does
not mean communism will prevail okay
uh technically our form of government is
representative with mix of socialism
marxism okay so there is a little bit of
communism in there isn't it i mean
education health uh
uh social security there's a little bit
of socialism in fact when you go to
college they talk about a mixed economy
they don't meaning it's got a little bit
of both you know free market and some
things have to be done
uh to help people or at least that's
what the government's
really all the governments on earth
ended up with
i think every government on earth has a
mixed economy there is no net pure
capitalist economy there's no pure in
fact nothing close to it to communism or
socialism they're all they're all
capitalists they're all mixed economies
even north korea is a mixed economy
cuba for sure i've been there you know
it's a mixed economy you have this
black market that works very well
and uh and then the government says look
if you don't interfere in politics we
won't interfere in your daily
black market out there
and so the government looks the other
way as long as you don't
get involved in politics and don't tell
the government what to do politically
and leave the
rulers in place then they have no
problem go ahead and do whatever you
have to out there on the streets survive
any way you can that's that's how it
works so there is no free market
economy and there is no socialist
economy all
countries on earth today have mixed
systems okay now some people see that as
communism other people say it's too much
capitalism
they're all mixed economies okay
and government know they can no longer
borrow endlessly yeah but that's what
they're doing that's how they're uh
solving these problems okay they're
borrowing they're creating money okay
and so they have gone along with a great
reset mr klaus schwab there who invented
this great reset he says after this
covet is gone
this is our chance to redo the economy
we go back to
um
a communistic ruling system and i guess
that's what he's thinking about he says
in a few years uh i think by 2030 or
whatever
uh you will have nothing you will own
nothing and you will be happy
that's what he says okay that's the
right reset because it is authoritarian
and they desperately want to hold on to
winning power it is doomed to failure in
other words uh
the powers that be
the new world order people the
illuminati whatever you want to call
them there's a
people out there billionaires they
control the economy and they want to
continue holding on to their world to
their power and they're not going to
allow the masses the poor people to take
over
you know their privileges okay that's
that's what people have in mind not only
this well but a lot of people think like
that we will see a new form of
government uh uh post-2030s
uh i think we won't see any kind of
government after 2030 i think we won't
be around to see anything okay the
extinction event for government is
already in place
uh in play okay uh yeah uh some people
think that um
we're just uh transitioning into
what marx originally said a world
government that eventually ends up in
anarchy meaning not again the guy with
the hand grenade anarchy meaning no
government because government itself
will cease to exist that's what marx
proposed he said it goes through
communism it doesn't go through
capitalism okay
uh i don't think it'll ever happen i
used to think it did but no longer no
way i think uh after the economy's
collapse especially the u.s economy
it's the end of the world for all of us
so all we can do is prop up the u.s
economy pray you know that uh it doesn't
fall do whatever you can to help the
united states economy stay afloat
because if
not yet but when it collapses it's going
to be the end of us
okay uh what a chinese empire this big
emperor that's
uh getting ahead of everyone what is it
concerned about well it's concerned
about something else it's concerned
about
uh the fact that they're having more
effeminate men
now is that a worry for an empire
and the article that times came up with
this week says uh uh has uh china has
begun to worry about the manliness of
its men
last week the chinese authorities banned
a feminine men from appearing on tv and
instructed broadcasters to promote
revolutionary culture
meaning macho right and so the article
goes on to say that past empires were
always worried about uh their
effeminate men which according to the
article always were around okay
and uh so you know you can't build an
empire according to the article on
effeminate men you need macho men to do
it you know i guess uh type a
uh
men out there and so now they're worried
about that it turns out this is all over
the world right we have it um effeminate
men everywhere on planet earth just
about every country has it even those
that deny it like uh iran and some of
the arab countries you know they do
execute people there
uh for
uh being homosexual not not being but
for carrying out homosexual acts
and uh iran has executed a couple out
there you know two or three people maybe
more i don't know but i know they've
executed a few and so um is this
happening all over the world
will that impact in any way
um
the collapse of the economy does that
have anything to do at all with the
economy does it have anything to do with
what i propose uh genetic diversity loss
of genetic diversity inbreeding leads
eventually
some species to end up with
homosexuality
okay that's my general argument on that
okay um
here's another
comment bell says if you want to
increase the birth rate no problem
increasing the birth rate is so easy
just take all women's privileges away
boom problem solved
he wants to go back to the old days
where you could
slap a woman you know and put her in the
right place you know what i mean
if i do that to my wife she'll kill me
[Laughter]
so i don't don't even dare to do that
anymore
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know if we're going back to
the good old days
if you can call them good old days you
know i mean it was was that good was
that bad
uh did we make progress or did we go
back in time by allowing women to be our
equals
how did we allow that to happen
well i think it was inevitable i think
uh
there was no way to avoid it and uh so
it's not a question whether it's good or
bad really it's i don't think i don't
look at it that way at all i look at it
it was inevitable it happens we have it
live with it okay that's all we can say
you know i think you can't turn it back
uh to the old days uh what do you want
to turn it back to the days of greece
where man
the head of the house
right the patriarch he had power of life
and death over everyone in the house his
sons
his daughters his wife the slaves the
whole works
now that was power okay because he was
responsible for his clan right so to
speak so if someone did something
he said i'm going to punish him
and if necessary he was authorized to
kill that person in the household that's
how much power a man had should we go
back to those days
well i think a lot of women would oppose
that and remember about 50 of the
population in the world
are women so i don't think they're gonna
vote for that
okay
so uh you know you may be out of uh time
if you think in those terms maybe you
should join the taliban in afghanistan
or something
okay
you should really read uh the shock of
the old by david edgerton it's relevant
to your theory about the transition from
industry to services
and
edgerton points out that the history of
technology is all wrong including the
aforementioned transition
i don't know about that so i looked up
uh mr edgerton
and he wrote this uh book called the
shock of the old and the guardian just
has a from
great britain has a little comment okay
on it did a little analysis says
edgerton points out an obvious but under
appreciated truth invention is not the
same as utilization in other words he
makes an uh distinction between
invention and innovation okay
uh in the 1960s great chunks of
government money went into concord but
railways a two century old technology
now carry millions of people each month
while supersonic passenger jets carry
none okay so we're still using old
technology and that's what's important
and not the fact that you invented
something new which nobody uses okay
that's that's the general argument
uh for consumers following prices of
goods invented long ago such as washing
machines matter at least as much as
anything new
even mobile phones or phones are used
mainly for talking possibly on landlines
it's possible on landlines a century ago
okay so that's the argument
and all i can say is this is uh this
fellow says that this transition is not
correct
i don't know i have a different view and
this is my view okay
uh here's the global decline of
manufacturing
and i think those uh numbers speak for
themselves okay you can see that every
country essentially has come down as far
as may as a percentage of uh
manufacturing of their specific economy
we're talking about the most uh
important economies on the planet and
they've all come down okay so so right
now we have um we have a problem with um
with
manufacturing that
it's being replaced by services and i
don't think we can revert this trend
anymore okay
i think agriculture was replaced by
manufacturing manufacturing is now being
replaced by services and that transition
is there the numbers are there if you
don't believe it or edgerton doesn't
believe it well i don't know what to say
you know i'm just saying those are the
numbers the numbers are that every
country on the planet is moving from
manufacturing to services what i mean by
that that i mean that the economies uh
the gross domestic product of each
economy of each nation
uh is becoming a the bigger percentage
is becoming services because they're all
imitating the advanced nations which
already are there the 80 85 percent of
the u.s economy of the european economy
a japanese economy is services now they
do services and only about 15 percent is
manufacturing
uh and anywhere from 15 to maybe 19 and
you got one percent of agriculture
that's how it's divided the labor force
and gdp
and so yeah this transition has already
happened you've already if you were born
in the 1980s you already were born
in a world
of services that started becoming more
and more
services and less and less manufacturing
that transition is already there so i
don't know uh
uh
i'm not sure edgerton argued that maybe
this volume interpreted wrong but for
sure for sure that's not the case
okay here we have uh another final one
issue says what uh what what about
massive sustained storage of foodstuffs
he's saying what about
because i'm saying that food the absence
of food is what's going to cause our
extinction
the absence of food is going to occur
because manufacturing companies
companies that agricultural companies
right that produce and distribute
food will no longer have an incentive to
do it if the global economy collapses
meaning meaning
money is no more nobody will accept
money okay and again that's a long story
but uh that's the general idea and so
this fellow says well what about the
foodstuffs that governments are storing
underneath the ground or wherever okay
that's what his argument is says
by elite government agency they have
been preparing for human extinction
events for a long time several decades
maybe okay essentially for the elite
subculture alone could that provide a
reasonable conceptual bridge to a
devastated human economy any newly
created local and then regional
government endorsed
economies
and uh all i can show you is uh there's
several arguments there and uh here's
i'm gonna show you the
biggest storage facility on the planet
okay
and a food okay it's a refrigerator a
big warehouse that's turned into a
refrigerator the biggest refrigerator on
earth it's in the state of washington
and it's known as the polar way because
that's the street on which it's on
and it's a cold storage facility located
in washington where it dominates the
northern landscape okay it is both the
largest refrigerated warehouse and the
largest automated freezer on earth okay
the warehouse has an area of la la la
okay says all that it says uh facility
is capable of storing about
350 million pounds of frozen food
okay
an average uh human uh eats anywhere
between four and five
pounds of food per day
so these hundred 350 million pounds
would
feed 90 million people one day
that's how much food is stored in this
warehouse which is the largest warehouse
on earth okay i want you to look at the
numbers here the percentage is the
ratios okay and right now the ratios are
not very favorable how much food do you
think the world stores
wherever underneath the ground above the
ground in storage facilities and so on
you know you had the situation another
communistic
situation
where first reagan and then since then
many times it's happened many times
happened in 2016 2018 it's already
happened
happened in 2019 as well
where uh cheese
uh
has been overproduced
by the people who have cows you know
they milk the cows and if they don't
store that
uh milk in some way it rots and so they
turn it into cheese because it's it
lasts longer and even that is not
consumed fast enough and they don't know
what to do with it
and so the government buys it
subsidizing the dairy industry
and partly because you know like
countries like china may buy a lot one
year and then they don't buy enough the
next year for political reasons or for
whatever reasons and suddenly you know
the these uh dairy farms they produce
too much milk too much cheese whatever
we do with it we don't have enough
consumers who are going to sell it to
the klingons and so
so they say okay what do we do now and
the government buys it puts it in
uh storages
and today one of the solutions they've
given that is to give it to pantries
people who
you know give food to the poor and so on
but even that's not enough to consume
all that all that cheese
and so the question is you know how long
do we store food
uh for for people that's one issue the
other issue is that if the global
economy collapses especially the u.s
economy
um
are you gonna have access to that food
that is being stored somewhere
once money is no more once everybody's
running for their lives
you know do you know where they're
storing all that food
that's one issue and the other one is
even if you knew are you close by to it
can you go in there and break the doors
down with a hatchet
and then uh
and then you have the issue of you know
those people who are in charge of those
who they're probably gonna take that
food first before you get there okay so
there's a lot of issues you gotta
consider when you when you talk about
storaging storing food okay
it's not like uh oh there's enough food
stored there for many years or
and uh if the whole world collapses and
there's no food the government will come
and feed me or i can go there and serve
myself
you know you better find out something
about that okay if you're interested in
the subject
anyways uh that's the
story today for extinction okay
let's move on to physics and today we're
going to be looking at
a couple more uh
clues that mother nature gives us
regarding opacity and transparency we
covered two of them okay
and so let me review that real quick
okay the first one is
um
that
i'm saying that if you
uh
misalign something
there's a tendency for it to become
opaque okay
and the proof the evidence the
the thing that convinces people usually
is some kind of evidence all i'm showing
is one example that mother nature has
and that's polarization and here we did
an experiment okay and you can see that
when the two lenses are aligned the
laser
uh
goes through when when you
misalign them you put 190 degrees to the
other the laser does not go through
so in one case we have here we have
transparency it goes through
uh someone called it translucent and i
don't use the word translucent
uh because it's essentially means the
same thing as transparency there's very
little difference just a matter of
degrees and dispersion so i'm just going
black and white here i'm saying
transparent and opacity opaque opacity
right and here you can see that uh it's
opaque in one direction you can't see if
you were uh if you had your eyes on that
board there on the back
uh you would not be able to see the
light whereas if we turn it like it is
now then you would see the light so yes
uh
just by
modifying the location of the atoms of
the molecules that comprise these two
lenses we can make something opaque and
transparent
uh without anything else
okay so uh that's uh
what i showed there how do we explain it
under the rope model or here i showed it
again i'm not going to go in detail
because i've covered this in the last
couple sessions again here it is i'm
saying that if those are the atoms the
molecules that build up the
lenses and i'm using the example of
calcium or carbonate
the ropes are lined
straight ahead and
both lenses are aligned all the atoms
are facing in the same direction on both
lenses once we turn one of them uh
sideways and here i'm going to show that
okay
what happens the ropes are no longer the
same ropes are no longer connected
straight ahead okay that's
one of the mechanisms that i'm proposing
okay
and again this is a proposal for you to
ponder for you to think about
uh people say have you proved it no we
don't prove in science so we just
explain the mechanism so that you
understand it you reach your own
conclusions if that's possible or not if
what i just explained is possible or not
the other one is uh again you know you
have the rope
and we're going to turn one of the
polarizers the one in the back we're
going to say this fist here this one
here is one of the
polarizers at one of the atoms of the
polarizer here's another atom and if you
turn it just uh 90 degrees you can see
what's happening the length of the
links
it changes okay so it's not the same
here as it is here okay that's another
thing that happens when you rotate one
of the polarizers okay so those two
things are things that you got to keep
in mind when you're analyzing
the alignment of
molecules
and so the question is
would you be able to see through a brick
wall you know if god you know with this
magic wand and made all the atoms or
molecules of the brick
be aligned if they were all aligned
would you be able to see
a light coming from the other side of
the wall for example okay so that's for
you to think for you to ponder okay
and uh some people have problems with
that and again that's because they're
tied to
the 19th century
they're still living in the 19th century
here it is
phel says polarization has absolutely
nothing to do with materials being
transparent i covered that the other day
we just look at the definitions of
transparent and opaque and we find out
that that's exactly what transparent and
opaque mean it's does light go through
or not okay and that's the quantum
version okay so
yeah polarization either allows the
light to go through using quantum
version right or it doesn't and so yeah
polarization does uh have a lot to do
with uh
with this subject matter that i'm
talking about which is uh opacity and
transparency
okay another issue that was raised by
another fella
says let us try one more time okay
it says uh water molecules uh in for
example swimming pool are not aligned
and yet water is highly transparent what
gives okay
and um here we see
another fella who says so the idea is
that transparency has something to do
with molecular alignment i don't know
bill i think that the other guy who
mentioned water molecules is right he's
referring to the guy on the left
okay and uh and then he adds to that he
says
glass which has disordered amorphous
molecular structure is about as
transparent as quartz chemically the
same but structured crystalline line
okay if light is torsional couldn't it
be more of a matter of stiffness
example metal is reflective because uh
it is too stiff to relay the torsion
okay so um what do we answer these uh
these gentlemen okay let's uh go with
the first one okay
and uh it goes like this
uh i'm going to try it one more time as
well
alignment is not the only mechanism
mother nature uses to do transparency
let me repeat that because they haven't
heard yet alignment is not the only
mechanism i'm trying to
go through the different mechanisms i
covered one and they already said oh but
the water molecules are aren't aligned i
never said that they did they were
aligned and that's the reason water is
transparent or air is transparent i
suggested that one one of the mechanisms
mother nature uses is alignment okay so
this is keep in mind the context here
okay we're saying that one of the
mechanisms is alignment
the second issue is
are water molecules in a swimming pool
aligned or not
because these people take for granted
that water is not aligned they say oh
water molecules move in every which way
and so the question is do water
molecules rotate 90 degrees when you
tilt the glass of water yes or no
if we leave the water for a long time
just sitting there right
three days whatever you want and allow
it to settle down will all the molecules
be facing in the same direction due to
gravity
okay these are the questions before you
okay these are questions okay
uh
questions whether we have an answer to
them or not uh and right now all i'm
doing is asking the question because
these people take for granted that
molecules
are not aligned water and air molecules
are not aligned they imagine all these
molecules just going in all different
directions because that's what they
learned in high school or college
is that the case
so let's go one more time over and so
that you understand what the issue is
what the question is right now you don't
even understand the question okay so
let's go with the question with what the
issues are
here's the experiment we did with hans
my son
we turned water around
okay we had it horizontal
and now we turned it vertical
vertically right never do this
except in the presence of a relativist
okay so when we turn the water around
did the water molecules the individual
water molecules there the gazillions of
water molecules did they also turned
around 90 degrees or did they remain at
the sa in the same direction with
respect to the center of the earth
that's the question before you
let's continue so that everybody
understands what the question right now
we these people are not even
understanding the question okay i need
to make sure people understand what the
question what the issues are okay
here we have a water molecule we have
two hydrogen one oxygen
okay
and i put it facing in that direction
arbitrarily okay this is arbitrary i'm
just putting it in that direction why
did i choose that specific direction
okay here is why i chose that direction
the oxygen has eight ropes connected to
any atom in the universe whereas the
hydrogens only have one rope why is that
because every element in the
periodic table
is simply an agglomeration or a uh
it's just a bunch of hydrogen atoms
so uh uranium for example has 92 atoms
uh what are we talking about we're
saying it's got 92
hydrogen atoms in it essentially it's
got some
neutrons as well but we're not going to
talk about that right now i'm just
saying that what we have is at least 92
hydrogen atoms in in a uranium atom and
so here we have oxygen oxygen's element
number eight and so yeah it's got eight
ropes it's got eight hydrogen atoms
that's why i put it in that direction
it's again arbitrary but i just put it
in that direction to make a point
what's the point that i'm trying to make
let's see if these people understand
what the issues are okay
here's the issue the issue is when you
turn water around does the water
molecule also turn around and stand on
its head
or does it remain
pointing in the same direction as the
one on the left
okay that's the issue before you
okay
and uh here we have
um
here we have the whole bunch of
atoms or molecules really in this case
okay water molecules and you can see
what's happening to them we turn them
around and the question is
does the water molecule also turn on its
side or does it remain like the one on
the left always pointing in the same
direction when you turn the glass around
okay
and i don't know if i'm getting through
to these people but uh hopefully
intelligent people can understand what
i'm saying i'm saying does
does the water molecule stand on its
head or on its side or however you want
to see that okay and here's a another
analogy okay so that maybe some
some of these people might be able to
pick up on that here you have all these
um dummies
soccer dummies that they use to practice
and you can push it on the side but then
it comes back to its original position
so maybe when when we turn the glass
around
uh you know sideways
uh it could be
that momentarily because of friction
uh the
the molecules momentarily move in some
direction okay but then do they come
back to their normal position which is
pointing in the same direction with
respect to the center of the earth
and people say now they're all jumbled
up they're all moving around in
different directions
are they
have we ever seen a an oxygen uh oxygen
molecule meaning you know air o2 okay
have we ever seen
any um
water molecule
no we have not we we cannot see and add
officially a hydrogen atom okay we
cannot see it
with the most powerful microscope that
you can imagine we cannot see a hydrogen
atom we've never seen a hydrogen atom
that's why the quantum mechanics have no
idea what a
hydrogen atom looks like
they can't draw one for you
they say it's a little ball with a
little electron b going around it
you know and you say okay can can you
show me the
photograph that you took of that
and no they cannot
because the model is ridiculous you
cannot explain why that electron bead
doesn't fly away automatically you know
on its own or fall to the nucleus so
they use that model because they have to
explain ionization and electricity and
who knows what else
uh you know quantum jump
but it's an irrational
model because they cannot explain again
why that electron beat stays faithful to
that proton uh in the center proton
bowling ball as i call it okay so this
is the issue and and so the question is
if they have never seen a hydrogen atom
and they have never seen a water
molecule one water molecule when you
turn the glass around
did the water molecules turn on their
side
maybe you shook them a little bit
because you know they're all touching
against each other and
once at the edge touch the edge of the
glass okay you got to consider all these
things there but then the question is
you know is that just a quick
momentarily
uh
thing that happened like with a
dummy the soccer dummies you push them
down momentarily it's down but
immediately it stands up okay all by
itself why because it's pointed towards
the gravity is pointed towards the
ground to the center of the earth so
this is what the issues are okay
uh so it's for you to ponder
okay you gotta think you gotta this is
food for thought
okay i hope people are understanding
some of this
okay what's the second mechanism that we
covered here it is okay and it's the one
that uh
quantum mechanics says
uh it says that if a photon
comes in and hits an electron it compels
it
to jump to a new energy level
when that happens only when it happens
if the uh photon has enough energy to
push it up there then uh the
electron b the photon beat is absorbed
and it doesn't reach your eyes and the
material is opaque
but if for some reason the
electron ball the
purple one there does not absorb that
photon
then the photon reaches your eye and the
uh material is transparent that's
essentially the other it's a little more
involved than that i'm just
reviewing it very quickly so if it
absorbs it it doesn't reach your eye if
it doesn't absorb it it reaches your eye
that's the difference between opaque and
transparent according to quantum
mechanics one of the arguments out there
probably the most important one okay
and so the issue here is that um we
showed the other day that if uh you put
one layer of plastic there that i put
you can see the uh light and a candle
but when you put many layers like i do
here you can't see that light at all and
so the question is
what prevented
the
light from reaching my eyes if all i did
was put more layers of that plastic i
mean shouldn't the photon
still go through
all those uh atoms that are between
my eye and the uh and the candle
and because none of them are absorbed in
other words the photon would have to
pick up more and more energies it goes
along until it's finally absorbed
by some
you know by one of the atoms of of those
layers of plastic
and and then it doesn't reach my eye
and so how did the photon gain
more and more energy to finally be able
to hit an electron and knock it to a
higher energy level that's the question
before you okay so what i'm showing with
this is that you cannot
use that mechanism to explain what we're
seeing there okay uh if we put more of
um
more layers of something in this case it
was this plastic okay
and if you put more and more layers of
this
that's all i did just put more layers at
some point
you can't see the
candle the light it's light i can't see
the light
anymore it's just a matter of how many
layers i put in there and if quantum is
right and it's all about the photon
being absorbed
uh by an electron meaning the electron
has to have sufficient energy to knock
it to
the uh
higher energy level if it has that then
it's absorbed
and so
are we saying that by putting more
layers the electron
the photon gained more and more energy
that at some point it was able to knock
an electron to the higher energy level
is that what these people are saying
obviously that's nonsense it's poppy cut
okay so you cannot explain it with that
mechanism that quantum mechanics has
okay a couple fellas uh
insist
okay so microwaves does go through walls
my wi-fi works through walls okay
and so he says these waves whatever they
are they go through his walls very scary
stuff
and the other fellow says light goes
through transparent materials
okay so here's a material a wall
and
he says it goes through it i guess he's
talking about particles or waves maybe
like the previous guy
um is that's what's happening is it
going through
and the first problem with this is what
i showed the other day and so these
people haven't listened so i'm going to
put it again i'm sorry i have to do this
for those people who are intelligent but
these people are obviously not very
smart okay because they're insisting on
something that cannot be they talk about
going through traveling through
and what they're referring is to this to
particles or waves
well the particles especially the
quantum particles are not particles
they're not corpuscles they're not
uh beads so you can't use the word
particle to give a physical
interpretation for transparency
or opacity and transverse waves are not
physical objects what you're staring at
there is what you're staring at vectors
what you're seeing is those blue and
red arrows they're vectors they're
mathematical vectors a vector is
magnitude and direction that's what the
arrow stands for they've got these
things moving and people think they're
looking at oh i know what i'm staring at
i'm staring at a wave no there is no
physical object called a wave and there
is no physical object in quantum called
a particle
okay so once you understand that you
cannot use this term going through or
traveling through like these two
uh gentlemen are talking about here you
can't use waves and you can't use the
quantum particle so-called particle so
the question is what is going through
they they claim that
that
waves and part or and or particles right
are going through their walls
and so first you got to tell me what it
is that's going through your walls you
got to tell me what um
physical object we have there that's the
first one don't say that waves go
through my wall or light the particles
go through my wall tell me what the what
those particles are okay and then tell
me how by what mechanism they go through
your wall
again can you shoot
a bullet in fact a bullet can you shoot
a bullet through the wall
uh
more than likely it it'll you know
get uh smashed into the wall and it'll
stay there it won't go through the wall
as if the wall weren't there the wall is
not transparent to bullets and why would
the photon
go through a wall in the same way we
have a little bullet there that's going
through the wall
what is going through the wall what
physical object you have to identify the
physical object before you even talk
about going through
okay and so that's the task that these
people have
under the rope model
uh it doesn't go through what we have is
relay
what you have is two atoms one atom from
the source connected to the the wall
and then the wall
atom is connected to another atom behind
it
and
in some cases it goes through and it's
transparent in some cases it doesn't go
through in and it's opaque and we're
covering those
mechanisms that mother nature uses
okay and so all i'm saying this is the
mechanism we have it doesn't go through
light doesn't go through anything light
simply is relayed from atom to atom
whether it's a wall or whether it's a
glass
air or water it doesn't matter it's
always relayed from atom to atom okay
this is a new mechanism that we're
proposing okay again food for thought
for people who have an open mind and can
analyze these uh situations
okay uh another follow
today was uh question driven because
they were all pertinent okay so here
another foul says i didn't understand
the part about reflection not occurring
at the surface of the water
okay
i saw a reflection both on the surface
and at the bottom where the mirror was i
showed an experiment where
i have a mirror at the bottom of a trash
can and i filled it with water and i
show that
i can always see the mirror with water
and without water
so i'm seeing all the way through the
water all the way to the bottom
and so this person is questioning that
he says well i thought a reflection is
from like most people think is from the
top of the water from the surface of the
water
and what they're thinking about is this
good old narcissus you know
they say well when i look at the water i
can see my reflection is that reflection
coming from the deep
uh ocean from the sand at the bottom of
the ocean or is it coming from the
surface of the water
and what we're talking about is two
different things here
the one on the left we're saying look if
you drop a coin or in this case a shoe
like i showed there
at the bottom of the pool okay
why can you see the shoe
i'm not talking about you looking at
your face in the surface of the water
i'm talking about seeing the shoe that's
at the bottom of the pool
and what you have to answer is
how did the light from the shoe get to
the surface of the water
that's the question before you how is it
that i can see that shoe which is at the
bottom of the pool okay
am i just looking at the reflection at
the surface and if so fine yeah i'll
accept that and then you have to tell me
how that
light got from the shoe at the bottom
the real shoe at the bottom of the pool
all the way to the surface okay so
that's what you gotta explain
so if you drop a coin somewhere you know
in the uh
fountain fountain of youth okay
uh why can you see the coin and you can
say well you know i can see my
reflection
at the surface yeah but how come you can
see the coin which is at the bottom of
the pool
that's the situation that you gotta
answer that's the question before you
okay another fellow says
two-way mirrors have cody actually it's
a one-way mirror okay
one direction it's a mirror in the other
direction it's glass you can see through
okay as you can see here mr bean he's in
front there he sees a mirror what do the
people on the other side see well they
see him doing all this
fancy stuff okay
so the question is if i have a laser
if mr bean has a laser then points it at
the mirror
he's going to get a reflection it's
going to come back to him it's not going
to go through on the other hand the
other folks
you know send the laser
he's going to receive the laser on the
other side or not
okay so the question is
the laser goes in one direction but not
in another direction
okay this is the issue
and it's the same material no matter
what
here here they can see him he cannot see
them
in one direction it's transparent in the
other one it's not it's opaque
uh being
mirror
we'll call that opaque
okay so the issue is
light goes in one direction and not in
the other direction and it's always the
same a mirror the same material the same
atoms the same molecules
okay so the question is if quantum is
correct why didn't the electron absorb
it
in one direction why did it allow it to
pass in another direction
okay so this is the issue before you
okay
and again i'm highlighting all these
issues because these people have very
short attention spans and they do not
understand what's in front of them
they're they're so brainwashed by what
they learned in high school in college
and they got a mumble jumble in their
head and they come up with all these
questions they're not listening they're
not even paying attention to what
they're staring at
okay so again you have a one-way mirror
the mirror is so thick
i don't care if it's coated or not
coated it's irrelevant
light goes in one direction it doesn't
go in the other direction it's always
the same material between the two lasers
okay so uh how does quantum explain it
electrons absorb photons is that how
quantum explains it
okay so this is the issue before you
okay uh today we're going to go through
the third mechanism that i'm going to
propose okay related to opacity and
transparency and it's got to do with
temperature okay
and here it is okay if you take argon
okay
and you take argon which is solid or
argon that is liquid either one of those
are transparent and again i'm going to
use the word translucent we're going to
use the word transparent we're just
going to say that light goes through it
according to quantum okay
according to a rope we have relaying of
light according to quantum light is
going through
uh this and reaching your eyes so that
you can see what's behind the
glass the
liquid argon or the
solid argon
okay
but what happens if we heat it up
in fact
normal state of argon is this one the
one you're going to see
and that's uh argon gas
when you have argon gas it becomes uh
opaque
it has this
violet color
no longer is transparent okay
and so the question is
how did all we did was change the
temperature
and suddenly uh we had we go from
from opaque uh to transparent or from
transparent to opaque just by changing
temperature obviously something is
happening with the temperature okay so
temperature is another clue i guess you
could say
that mother nature gives us on how she
plays around with transparency and
opacity okay so that's the point i'm
trying to make
uh let me show you another magic trick
mother nature does okay keep these in
mind so that you can factor them into
your
own theories into your own conclusions
okay
and here it is we have liquid oxygen and
suddenly you know oxygen out there in
here in the air
is transparent so is nitrogen i mean 80
of the air we breathe is said to be
nitrogen okay about 19 is oxygen okay
and so both of them are transparent
but when you freeze
you start um freezing oxygen it turns
into this bluish color and it's no
longer transparent and all we did was
change the temperature
okay so you get air
and you can't see it
somehow you you are able to freeze it to
a certain temperature
and it becomes opaque comes blue like
that it's no longer transparent
okay we got that
temperature seems to affect argon
temperature seems to affect
oxygen also affects nitrogen you look at
liquid nitrogen and so on you'll see
something some difference than the
nitrogen that you breathe every day okay
and here's another picture of that
liquid oxygen and solid oxygen you can
see it's turning somewhat bluish
okay and you can see it's no longer
transparent and all you did was change
the temperature okay so the question is
what hap what does temperature do to
objects
that suddenly converts them into
transparent or opaque depending on which
way you go with the temperature
something is happening with this thing
we call temperature
okay something's something's going on
okay and so this is another clue that
mother nature gives us you know here
it's opaque same material now different
temperature now
now it's uh transparent
i hope i hope that sunk in somebody's
head out there
okay
okay so i ran an experiment okay a very
dangerous experiment always do it in the
presence of a trained relativist okay
this is a very expensive experiment i'm
not sure if all of you can afford it
okay so
it may be out of your
budget okay what i did was i took a
little pen and stuck it into a glass and
froze the glass
in my freezer
okay so what happened i did a time lapse
of this glass and you can see what
happens it melts
and suddenly the pen comes into view
okay
i took different photographs like every
20
30 minutes
so it's not
perfectly stable but it doesn't matter i
guess you get my point point is that the
guy on the left is opaque the one on the
right is transparent we did this with
temperature alone it's the same material
it's the same water i didn't change the
water all i did was melt whatever was in
there which was ice
and you can see the pen comes into view
suddenly what was opaque became
transparent
okay we did this only with temperature
okay so um
so
what happened well
you know how do we explain this well
what's going on here you mean there's
this thing called temperature whatever
temperature is
that suddenly turns materials from
opaque to transparent transparent to
opaque depending on which way you go
with the so-called temperature
okay so uh here's an example of
how quantum mechanics
explains it versus how the rope model
explains it okay
and
you can see here this is from my book
why god doesn't exist okay
and you can see quantum water uh they
have these things
they call hydrogen bonds
okay hydrogen bonds and water is somehow
you know these hydrogen bonds are
flexible or loose or whatever you want
to call it
and when you freeze the thing these
become like sticks
you have this crystal structure suddenly
in the water
turned into ice you know so now these
connections whatever you want to call
these hydrogen bonds turn into solid
things and they're straight and you know
not even samson can break them okay
under the rope model it's the rope
bro uh all atoms are interconnected by
ropes what we're saying is the rope
suddenly um
becomes uh
in other words has
less
frequency it has longer
uh link links longer links okay so we
call it link length which stands for the
wavelength of quantum mechanics
and so at some point when when that
[Music]
rope has such long
lengths
it's
frozen
what is heat heat is higher frequency
shorter links
and that's what we're going to call heat
and so that's the difference between
water and ice but we have a physical
object the physical object is the rope
that's the one that's either gaining
heat or losing heat meaning gaining
frequency or losing frequency right
and
with that we can explain you know what
the hydrogen bond is
what is the hydrogen bonding according
to quantum mechanics well here it is
this is the hydrogen bond okay this is
from uh
the wikipedia and uh there's a comment
there the last one the last paragraph
comes from another site it says what is
a hydrogen bond well it's an
electrostatic
what
force
what is a force is is a force a physical
object can you draw a picture of a force
can you bring it to me and say this is a
force
no force is a concept you can't say that
it's an electrostatic force that's not
is that what you're going to freeze an
electrostatic force
this is what quantum is saying okay
force of attraction between a hydrogen
atom and another atom
so they're saying they're freezing a
force
what sense does that mean it's like
saying i froze love
i froze time
i froze intelligence that's what i think
they froze
okay
the hydrogen bond can be viewed as a
metric dependent electrostatic scalar
what
field
is a field of physical object is there a
physical object you can bring a magnetic
field and put it in the center of the
conference room without the magnet
obviously
maybe you can bring up a gravitational
field
and put it in the center and show this
is a field
uh and if you don't bring it in can you
draw it what are you going to draw for a
field
field is defined
as values at each point in space that's
that's what a field is it's a it's a
concept mathematical concept
so for them to say that a hundred
hydrogen bond is a field of any kind
that does whatever it wants to do
is nonsense
a bond a thing right they're talking
about a stick because they're drawing it
as a stake cannot be a force or a field
there's those such physical objects as
force or field in science or physics
okay and uh then they explain this is
another site says during freezing water
molecules lose energy
whatever that is i mean what is energy
can you
bring energy and put that in a
conference room in the center of the
conference so that we can see it from
all around you know oh that's energy i
see what it is what is it
uh some kind of smoke
is it a gas what is this energy thingy
okay this is what you gotta explain yeah
lose energy and do not vibrate or move
around as vigorously
okay so yeah so the water molecule
doesn't vibrate as much great
and they lose energy whatever that is
energy is a mathematical concept so they
lose this mathematical concept
what sense does that make from a
physical interpretation point of view
absolutely none
this allows more stable hydrogen bonds
to form between water
molecules
and again it has to do with my
explanation here when they say they lose
energy
what we're saying is that the frequency
changed which is the one on the bottom
there along the rope what does that mean
well it means that the links become
longer and the longer they become the
colder they are the frequency is lower
and what you have is long links okay so
uh let's get rid of these so that you
can see here
give me a second here
get rid of these two
this is what i'm saying
uh
here we have a rope okay
and what we're saying is this is heat
high frequency short links
as you unwind the rope
it gets colder
the links become longer the frequency is
less
okay that's what we're saying there's
fewer links
and the more you untarget the colder it
is that's what coldness is
under the rope model
and yeah now you have a stick
and that's what the hydrogen bond is
okay it's a stick it's a stick made of
something hopefully there's something
there otherwise you're putting black
magic spirits in that space you're
saying that between two atoms there's a
hydrogen bond
and what's a hydrogen bond what's a
field what is a field what's a force
it's energy
those are just concepts you can't say
that it's energy field or force you got
to put a stick in there
what is that stick
why is it frozen why is it a solid state
under the robot or you can explain that
because there is a physical object in
that space between two atoms that we
cannot see or touch
okay
okay so uh let's do another experiment
this is a thought experiment okay for
you to ponder it's got to do with
temperature but in a different way okay
and here it is uh here we have we take
uh air
okay and we're gonna squeeze this air
air is transparent we're gonna squeeze
it now okay we're gonna compress it
same amount of air but in a smaller
volume does it become opaque
and when we release it and the air can
now expand again in the volume right
does it become transparent
this is a million dollar question okay
and uh
uh unfortunately uh the
well i don't know if unfortunately but
quantum mechanics cannot explain that at
all and here let me show you an example
okay
and this is for you to ponder about
anyone who's got a phd in mathematical
physics okay
here here you see their answer after
over 200 years that we've known
about gases and their relationship to
pressure and to temperature
okay and here you have two testimonies
there were a lot more by the way okay
you can look them up on your own but
one site uh it's a professional site
that sells cooling equipment says
pressure multiplied by volume divided by
temperature equals a constant
the combination law that's boyle's law
okay rubber boil and charles law okay
uh there you have them the equations
explains what happens to air when it
it's compressed into a smaller volume
okay it tells us that when air is
compressed the pressure and
temperature right
of the air increases we have higher
temperature according to this fellow
right or this site
as the volume of space containing air
decreases by pushing air into a smaller
space we force it to become hotter
okay
and more pressurized
what does the famous
uh stack exchange say says exactly the
opposite
okay it says in an ideal gas there is no
temperature
change upon compression or expansion the
only gases that come close to being
ideal at room temperature are helium
hydrogen and neon they actually slightly
cool
on compression and heat on expansion at
room temperature
and if you go to the stack exchange to
look up that you'll find at least five
different answers from all these great
phds and master's degrees and physics
mathematical physics and they all
contradict each other
and the the punch line or the icing on
the cake is that the stack exchange says
the question is not finished this the
question is still open for anyone who
wants to answer
so why don't you go there and tell them
that they're all a bunch of
well i'll withhold my opinion on that
uh i mean if after 200 years quantum
cannot ambiguity
unambiguously tell you
whether um
temperature goes up when you compress
if we have all these phds and masters
degree in mathematical physics and they
all still have just opinions there's no
unanimity not everyone thinks exactly
the same way on this issue after 200
years
then you should start questioning those
people who have phds in mathematical
physics
okay what did they study
or what did they memorize really okay
so uh
all i can do is do uh the same
experiment i just did the thought
experiment and i'm going to do it in
space this time around so that there is
no loss of heat to environment and all
that nonsense that they bring out okay
so here we do it in space okay we're
going to compress air in a box somehow
in space
and the same volume of air is not
allowed to escape
and we just compress it into a smaller
volume the question is will it become
opaque
when it's compressed will it become
transparent
uh when it comes out
what's your guess
okay
so again food for thought
and a lot of people say well bill tell
us the answer uh
you know really it's better not to give
you answers it's better for you to stop
start thinking about all these things
because if i give you the answer all you
did was memorize like all these people
did in college they went out there they
memorized whatever they were told and
they just repeat they parrot whatever
they've gotten they've got all this
logic to back them up and then you catch
them at the stack exchange you all have
different opinions
so this guy went to harvard the other
guy went to cambridge and this guy said
no no i learned that
the temperature goes down the other guy
said no the temperature goes up
after 200 years they still can't reach
an agreement
that's unbelievable it's it's really
incredible
okay uh so
people are probably going to answer that
uh next comments and i'm sure they're
just going to give their opinion that's
all they're going to give and everyone's
going to have a justification for their
opinion the question is that after 200
years we still have no
solid answer that everybody on earth
agrees to you would think that on this
issue they would all agree because after
200 years we should know
whether the temperature goes up or down
and they don't they all have opinions
that's what's incredible
okay so here are my conclusions
quantum particles are not corpuscles
okay let's make sure we understand that
corpuscles belong to classical mechanics
okay quantum particles are not particles
they use the word particles to mislead
and when you put them against the wall
they tell you well they're not really
particles so what are they what are
particles
you have to take 10 years of mathematics
at the university to understand what a
particle is that's the answer okay so
particles are not particles
they uh represent them when they give
you a physical interpretation they
represent them with balls with little
dots or whatever but when you put them
against the wall they say oh those are
mathematical what wave function
collapses is that what they are a field
collapse or whatever
quantum waves uh are concepts they're
moving vectors there is no physical
object called a wave wave is not only a
verb but it's an irrational verb because
what they're moving
are magnitudes and directions
they're moving numbers
and that is very scary
uh quantum
mechanics cannot explain transparency or
opacity with one-way mechanisms even if
we concede what these people are saying
they're saying that all these particles
or waves are going through the wall
whatever wall it doesn't matter they're
saying whether it's a wall of air wall
of water wall of glass or wall of bricks
they're saying it goes through the wall
in fact you just had a couple people say
there that their waves come through the
wall and feed their computers
their wi-fi or whatever
so the wave goes through the wall the
part of the i guess that's when they
talk about waves because everybody said
well yeah i can imagine a wave going
through a wall can a particle go through
a wall
i mean are we talking about photons
particles of light going through the
wall is that what's going through the
wall
so that's when they switch over the wave
and of course you won't find the wave in
the standard model of particles what
you'll find is particles no waves in
there never find a wave in there uh wave
is something that belongs to james
maxwell 19th century they only introduce
it when they can't explain it with
particles or when they want to mislead
you and say well here's the physical
interpretation we do it with waves
because how else are you going to
explain
uh for example you know the the verified
wave nature of light
you can't do that with particle is the
particle moving up or down
up and down i mean uh
why is it moving up what's pushing it up
why is it moving down so that's when
they introduce the wave and they say
well the wave you know what a wave is it
just goes up and down well what's going
up and down
and the answer of most
mathematical physics is
nothing nothing is moving up and down
that's the answer okay okay we
identified three clues
one is alignment
okay
uh the polarized uh lenses okay that's
one way mother nature uh distinguishes
between opacity and transparency
another one is quantity we put more
quantities of something and what was
transparent you put all these
transparents one one next to the other
and you turn it into opaque
and if you want to turn opaque into
transparent maybe you just got to make
it thinner
right maybe you have to align it you
know and now it becomes transparent
you know a piece of cheese you can take
a block of cheese well it's
it's uh
probably um opaque okay but if you make
it thin enough i mean if you could make
it one atom thin
maybe you could see through it
huh could it be
okay and then the other one that we
discussed today is temperature
okay whatever temperature is apparently
it's something
to do with frequency
with wavelength okay that's probably
what temperature has something to do
with maybe with the vibration of
molecules
which in turn affect
the ropes that interconnect the atoms
and molecules right
and so apparently temperature also is a
way mother nature
uh converts opaque into a
transparent and transparent into opaque
okay
food for thought
okay
okay folks let's go with some of the
questions i already covered some of the
questions that people asked because they
were pertinent to the
subject matter of today so let's go with
some of the other questions
false says
says i'd assume like in relay
through even a brick wall
yeah i like that the fact that he says
the word relay okay so he says relay
through that travels through or goes
through it says relay through okay now
we're getting the right language getting
closer to the right language think of it
when uh think of when a nuke goes bang
okay for that few split seconds unless
you're you're hiding behind thick
concrete walls or lead the light is
going to affect you
okay so he's saying
uh there's a relay mechanism and yeah as
long as you use the right wording i will
not i promise not to bend your head okay
and so here we see what this was talking
about uh if we use the one on the bottom
uh you're relaying but if you're going
to use the particles and
waves the one-way particles and waves
and talk about going through traveling
through the wall well we got a problem
because now you have to identify what
physical object we have up there
in the case of the rope no problem we
have a rope it's a physical object the
rope looks something like this you know
if you've never seen a rope go to a
hardware store ask for a rope you'll
know what i'm talking about that's the
model that we're introducing we're
saying that light is mediated by
rope-like dna like
entity
very soul very small very thin
imagine an atom
we can't see an atom we can't see a
hydrogen atom and here we're talking
about something which is gazillion
of uh uh times
thinner
or smaller than the atom
so you're doing something
unimaginably small
that's what we're talking about and so
yeah when people say well how come you
can't see or touch the ropes what can
you see or touch
uh you know an atom if you can't see
you're touching that and forget about
the rope the rope is gazillion
uh times uh
smaller thinner whatever you want to
call it than the uh
then the atom
okay another fellow says
the wavelength shifted until it could be
absorbed as thermal energy
what the hell is this energy energy
is change over time he says
so let's translate let's see what he
said let's put that in red there the
wavelength shifted until it could be
absorbed by thermal change over time
whatever that means i mean there is no
physical object called change
change is a verb it's a synonym of
motion so whenever you talk about change
you talk about motion whenever you talk
about motion you're talking about change
because they are synonyms that's what
change means motion
okay and so um
if energy is
uh
change
and again he talks about wavelength
shifting and we have no idea what he's
talking about until he can identify the
physical object
and change is not a physical object
we have no idea what he's proposing so
yeah he's got to work on it a little
more than he has so far
okay and here's a another issue well it
says regarding my single atom in the
laser question well will 10 atoms be
enough to produce coherent light i was
talking about the laser okay and uh
do something like this
okay there's the laser and so the
question is
um he said why is it directed why
doesn't the laser shine in every
direction i'm saying uh a laser is
directed light and so he says uh will 10
atoms be enough does the number of atoms
even matter
he doesn't have the slightest clue how
big an atom is
he doesn't have a
clue how
thin how small the rope is with respect
to the atom he has no clue whatsoever so
he talks about will then adam be enough
does he know what 10 atoms look like in
a row even if they're
next to each other so uh um i'm asking
him i'm answering with a question how
many atoms are one centimeter cube of
laser of light
if he can answer that question i'll
answer his okay does he have any clue
whatsoever how big
an atom is
and if the rope is gazillion
times smaller thinner
[Music]
than an atom
you know
is it does it make sense to ask what
he's asking
okay so this is the situation he needs
to understand how big things are
at the small level okay
and this micro
uh world that mother nature runs out
there that of atoms and ropes
okay so you need to
wrap your head around the sizes
how many atoms and are in one centimeter
cube of air for example do you have any
idea
you look it up look it up and you'll
you'll be scared because you can't even
imagine such a number
of atoms in such a small space let alone
the ropes that interconnect them
the gazillions of roads that
interconnect them and that are going
through that same space remember every
atom in the universe is connected to
every atom in the universe so not only
are the local atoms connected to each
other but you have atoms on the other
side of the universe that are going
right through the ropes going right
through that same space
that's how small how thin
the ropes are that interconnect the
atoms you're talking about something
unimaginably thin all you can do is
conceptualize it bring it into the macro
world by saying well it looks something
like this
and then people say why can't i see the
rope why can't i touch the rope well now
you know why because you can't even see
an atom
that's why
and so it's a stupid question for people
to say what crayola she's a roman
[Laughter]
that's how you want to bang over the
head okay another fellow says why would
you ever use the terms from irrational
science like light in order to explain
rope problem
well the first problem is i don't know
what rope problem he might be talking
about we have no problems in rope okay
so i'm not sure what real problem he's
got
we have no real problem where did you
get the notion that the word light
belongs to irrational science
i mean we all use the word light and
it's an informal term what does it mean
it means
it refers to the visible spectrum that's
when we say the light we usually refer
to what we can see
again very informally okay
and we talk about light being
the visible spectrum we always talk
about light as well
uh informally when we're in the
ultraviolet or beyond or in the infrared
or below
again we use that term light you have to
understand that the word light is simply
an informal term and what does it mean
what means two things it means the
entity
that mediates light as well as
the torsion in our case along that
mediator so light refers to the
noun and to the verb at the same time
when we say light we're referring to
not only you know
people say well light is what i see no
you're not seeing like we're not talking
about what you see you see the wall but
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about what mediates light
and what it's doing and we call that
light and we're referring to both the
noun and the verb in the case of
quantum mechanics it's particles
and they're flowing
so light is particles flowing many
particles flowing or wave that is waving
that's what the word light means in
quantum mechanics under the rope model
it means rope that is torquing
so light it has that meaning there is no
physical object called light but we use
it informally okay so let's just keep
things within the proper context and not
take them out of there
uh either to play devil's advocate or
anything because you're just barking up
a tree
okay another fellow i asked a different
question he talks about the word exist
and he says if exists can only be used
to describe objects
can we use another word like real for
concepts relationships attributes
uh
in physics real and exists are synonyms
okay so we just separate not real from
uh
from exist what we do is separate
ordinary speech from physics from
science okay that's what we do
and so that's the correct division not
the division between real and exists to
be able to refer to things whenever you
use the word real or exist in ordinary
speech it is meaningless because you
never defined a word in a uh
rational manner okay so we use it in
form when you say oh love
exists you can't say that in physics
and you can say love is real you haven't
said anything either and you said the
same thing as you love exists
in only in physics can use the word
consistently meaning uh you know this
rope this one right this rope exists
why because it's an object that's the
first condition and second it's got um
distance with respect to all objects in
the universe so we can say this rope
exists by definition because by
definition and here's the definition
okay for the word exist
that we can use consistently in science
right it says
exist
physical object physical presence uh an
object which is the physical part that
was just shape and location the set of
distances okay that separate one object
from all others so as long as the object
has uh location
you know it exists by definition
pursuant to the definition of exist
which is physical presence if god wants
to exist first he's got to be an object
he can't be love he can't be
intelligence he can't be any concept
can't be energy okay he's got to be a
physical object
and i use the word physical which is
redundant he's got to be an object okay
and then he's got to have location there
better be distance between god's chest
and mind if he wants to exist
and he's going to exist only pursuant to
the definition not because i believe or
stop believing or whatever it's got
nothing to do with belief it's got to do
with the fact that
we have a definition and whatever wants
to exist for the purposes of physics
must follow the definition
okay
and final issue here
we have a gentleman who says
he said the following he says uh bill
you should answer
um
what is it uh pewdiepie
uh late his latest video largest youtube
youtuber 110 million
subscribers and i'm verified yeah it's
110 million subscribers on multiverse
theories
it might attract some viewers to your
ideas
i hope not
i really hope not because uh he's got
110 million viewers and it turns out i
went there to find out you know what
what his uh site was about
and he talks about yeah this uh
multiverse thing
uh theory
and
you don't want to you don't want to
watch that i mean the guy just says you
know i don't know i have no i clue
that's all he says throughout his whole
presentation he has no idea he has no
clue but he's got 110 million
subscribers that listen to him saying
that he doesn't know and he has no clue
it's astounding
it's like a dumb blonde
uh trying to explain something you know
and uh what does she do she talks about
i don't know how what the hollywood
actor wears
you know and uh she spends all day long
just talking about that
i mean i think i would commit suicide if
i heard that for you 24 hours
and this is more or less the same thing
who watches
such nonsense uh such uh small talk
i mean people must have a lot of time on
their hands to watch a
a fella like this pewdiepie
he doesn't know squat
but he's got a lot of followers and
hopefully none of those followers come
to my site here you know i mean i don't
want all those dumb blondes coming over
here swapping my my uh channel i'd
rather keep it
low in volume
and have all these people talk about
nonsense and putting comments there that
have no relationship to physics now in
physics we try to
maintain science we try to keep it with
explanations and we don't care how many
viewers come here
uh we talk about physics here not about
uh how many hits i got okay
with that i'll see you next time i think
it's on wednesday we'll see you then
bye-bye